Останні приготування Адама Дарскі
та музик польської групи у жанрі Black Metal - "Бегемот" - у Варшаві.
Незабаром вони поїдуть у тур Європою, але спершу - три концерти у Польщі. Дарскі провокує.
Провокує не лише музично.
Aдам Дарскі - один з тих польських артистів, які виступають проти право-популістської
та антиєвропейської правлячої партії "Право і справедливість".
Я вважаю себе поляком, громадянином Польщі і так само європейцем.
Для мене це однаково важливо.
Я проти нинішнього курсу політиків, які керують вже два роки нашої країною.
Це штовхає нас в ізоляцію.
Свої політичні переконання Дарскі підкреслює художніми провокаціями.
І не лише ними.
У останньому альбомі групи - ціла колекція фотографій Дарского на біблійні мотиви.
Як, приміром, Ісус на перевернутому хресті.
Такі витівки багато кого дратують у Польщі -
країні, в якій католицька церква є надзвичайно консервативною і підтримує націоналістичний уряд.
Депутат Домінік Тарчинскі від правлячої партії вже навіть оголосив попередження артисту.
Він порушив закон.
Наше кримінальне право чітко визначає - не можна ображати релігію, будь-яку релігію.
Не можна зачіпати почуття віруючих. А він це зробив.
Для парламенту в Варшаві подібні сцени - не дивина:
як от цей католицький противник абортів з плакатом "Розмножуйтеся, а не скорочуйтеся".
З іншого боку - Aдам Дарскі зі своїми прихильниками.
Вони часто зустрічаються тут: музикант перетворює перукарні на сцену.
Не лише у Варшаві, але і в інших великих ліберальних містах країни.
Музика у жанрі Black Metal, стиль життя, політика.
Це суміш, з якою артист протестує проти націоналістично налаштованих,
на його думку, часто обмежених можновладців.
Нинішня політична ситуація в країні для мене неприйнятна.
Приміром, коли мене намагаються цензурувати через суди.
Мене викликають до поліції, на концерти приходять з таємних служб,
аби перевірити нас і переконатися, чи не плануємо ми якісь підривні дії.
Я вже пройшов через усе це.
Дарскі та "Бегемот" запевняють - це їх не залякає.
Підтримку вони відчувають і за кордоном -
у США музиканти грають на одній сцені з метрами хеві-металу, - як, власне, і вдома.
Тут усе зовісм не так, як надворі.
Там багато люті, в цьому я переконався на власному досвіді. А тут нікому нічого не загрожує.
Увечері - останні приготування перед концертом у Варшаві.
Адам Дарскі перевтілюється на сценічний персонаж і називає себе Нергал.
Це вавилонське божество, яке бореться проти чужої йому країни.
Музикант бачить себе саме таким.
Різниця лише у тому, що йдеться про його власну країну,
якою керують люди, ворожі ліберальному світогляду Дарскі.
Він хоче розбурхати людей, спонукати їх відкритися світові,
почати інакше думати і позбутися своїх старих переконань.
Він робить усе у дещо суперечливій манері.
На жаль, ми живемо у країні, де багато хто не хоче із цим миритися.
Дарского та його групу часто називають останніми співцями ліберальної Польщі.
Артист із цим не згоден.
У Польщі досі чимало вільних людей відстоюють свої дії та переконання.
Я не пророк і не месія. Хоча, безперечно, я вмію гарно виражати свої прагнення до свободи.
Aдам Дарскі та його "Бегемот" грають далі - це голос ліберальної Польщі.